il y à bien longtemps vivez la
civilisation casse tête selon la légende
elle serait à l'origine des casse tête
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est la
légende juste là oui celle-là cette
ingénieuse civilisation l'idée
paisiblement jusqu'au jour où le comte
isadore fabiano soli pardo cruse obsédés
par leur invention décida de détruire
les casse-têtes par frustration
plusieurs siècles plus tard un
conservateur de musée donne oscar aragon
toronto mais retrouve une énorme caisse
dans les archives de son musée ces
caisses est étiqueté au nom de fabien
olicard intrigué il décide de lui
envoyer pour en percer les secrets après
quelques galères pour la faire rentrer
dans les bureaux
fabien découvre enfin cette mystérieuse
boîte tintin
mais en fait le prochain casse tête on
pourra plus grands traits je sais même
pas comment vous avez rentrer ça dans ce
bureau sauf si sa santé se démontre
ok
j'ai reçu mes yeux l'orangerie où après
excusez moi je suis sur des basses
considérations mais on en fera quoi te
ça après si ça se trouve c'est un
rubik's cube dedans en fait et vous
m'avez brain on va découvrir ça
exploration ça c'est une corde je la
défaire je pense que c'est le genre de
cordoue où s'il casse tête est trop dur
tu peux te pendre avec ça vient d'un
musée simple
je pense qu'ils sont un peu trompé parce
que c'est pas amusé quoi ici quoi après
ça m'arrive de m'amuser
tu l'as où un jeune est allé comme par
hasard c'est fermé par des cadenas ça
commence peut-être après si je voulais
de cannes a peut-être après c'est fini
et là je dirais vous avez mal estimé le
niveau de difficulté d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que samedi soir le west coast
hockey petit autocollant un peu partout
origine tout cas elle pas quelque chose
musée de nascar reste
ce sont des tonnes à 4 chiffres voilà un
nom c'est pas un quatre chiffres en bas
c'est décidé c'est démodé symbole ce
genre de chose qu'est ce qu'on a ici
propriété du musée l'aps terium de
découverte péruvienne objets 65 un objet
religieux par aman donc il ya un numéro
de report la à tanger pas vu un truc
comme la lie 1,3 sur ce truc s'il y
avait un oeuf ici il ya un oeuf avec un
petit camino
là il ya 1 4 là il ya 1 3 ok ça fait
comme une petite bd ça a peut-être
l'ordre des trucs genre il ya le moulin
après ça serait mis à autre chose qu'on
pourrait compter des choses comme ça non
bon je m'y intéresse après mais il ya
une séquence
j'étais intrigué par sa des documents
vous savez
10 avenue des champs elysées paris 8e
c'est vraiment chez nous ça c'est sûr 15
mai 2003 mais les gars c'était long à
venir j'ai envie de les scanner le qr
code un petit mot ça doit être pour moi
trop rio le 14 mai 2003 je ne remet
absolument pas en cause les talons de
lecteurs de fabien mais je vais vous
résumer cette lettre et puis si vous
voulez la lyre vous pouvez toujours
faire pause en gros le conservateur du
musée donne oscar aragones tholot jo lui
fait parvenir cette boîte car il y avait
son nom dessus et lui demande s'il peut
l'aider à en percer les secrets et que
s'il y arrive il peut garder la boîte de
toute façon ça lui importe peu voilà
c'est reparti l'état aurait dû me donner
les codes du canard et combien
d'étiquettes y en a une une deux trois
quatre cinq six peut-être je donne
notifié quatre qui vont dans le même
sens entre guillemets qui racontent la
même chose là j'ai un moulin à vent
l'âge et la ciudad la g1
camino quel secret ça va
chauffer quelque chose notre 4 7 9 à
fait décent à brut
et là ça continue à ca brut alors ça
fait se doit de la en entier pour les
saf et se doit la en entier la presse a
fait un ongle pas 9 6 4 pourquoi pas 9
7 3 beaucoup je tombe de frouard sajan
c'était le 2 avant le 9 ça fait huit
jours on est dessus de ce carte sd plus
tard on a trouvé juste le code de ce
cadenas ou en fait fallait penser à un
seul paysage en éclats tes skis se
raccorder c'était la carte numéro 2 où
on avait la maison et le haut de la
colline ou de la montagne du moins qui
allait bien avec le haut de la montagne
d'ici et la maison d'ici ça après ça
allait bien avec le monsieur qui en 7 et
après ça j'ai cru que c'était raccorder
avec ça mais c'était pas la bonne
hauteur en fait c'était raccorder avec
ça donc le code était de 9 2 9 7 3
maintenant les lettres de pus musée
quand même pas mal c'est ni donc je vais
essayer de l'approcher
m
on a une piste c ap bp qui a répété
mille fois
d'autres qui a répété là donc on va
essayer de la paix bp vous cache pas que
si c'est ça j'ai un seul intergalactique
et après je serai un [ __ ] que
ça marchait pas d'essayer dotent d
eau
à crest et du thé des eaux a t il à il
ya ce petit truc qu'on peut tirer
[ __ ] mais ça ouvre [ __ ]
m et antin et c'est plus dur que
n'importe laquelle des vidéos
l'ouverture de la boîte j'ai plongé plus
en vie dure le truc c'est qu'à
l'intérieur il est censé y avoir un truc
chiant mais
c'est le prix de chemin composé en
puzzle en foire aux deux des watts est
ce qu'on vient de comprendre que des
eaux atc john oscar aragón toronto une
heure ça fait déjà une heure qu'on est
des cons et sur le casse tête
c'est beau
ça c'est un casse-tête ce nom ça
s'appelle un caillou incroyable c'est un
vrai truc aztèques en fait lâche 3 claps
terium en fait ils m'ont vraiment
envoyer un truc qu'ils ont volé dans un
musée
j'ai réussi encore une énigme là je
crois d épingler le dossier
[Musique]
je suis en train de faire un casse est
un explorateur je vous le dis voici le
dossier que j'ai reçus
cas bien vieillit 1 19 ans
on a des photos de ruines on a des
espèce de tableau de correspondance
1er 2e 3e l'oeil ouvre la voie vers le
savoir traduction je pense que c'est un
cadeau un carnet de route je commençais
par cette focale pas le 21 novembre 1980
un an et un jour avant la naissance
coïncidence je ne crois pas que c'est
moi à nouveau pour un petit résumé de la
lettre vous pouvez toujours faire pause
si ça vous intéresse de la lire en
intégralité une archéologue du nom de
estelle d'efforts à retrouver cette
relique dans des ruines casse tête elle
pense que c'est le dernier artefacts
caché par les casse tête peu après le
massacre commis par crous n'a pas réussi
à en percer les secrets et elle l'est
c'est un extrait de notes de traduction
dans l'espoir que ce soit utile voilà
c'est reparti déjà essayer de voir s'il
ya des choses amovible un peu
là des rotations quelque chose comme ça
qui sait
j'ai trouvé un prix cristal
en est un autre là j'en ai un ici dans
un petit bout de bois de la fouille de
la fouille il ya un très joli
et une grosse pointe
bonjour seniors pha bien sûr les garde
corps sain vous souvenez vous de moi
izel la dernière des casse tête vous
pensiez fontanes et la dernière trace de
l'existence de meubles et bien vous êtes
tombés dans le piège je me suis sacrifié
liés à la magie de notre art peu fade
pour vous apporter la mort et ainsi
obtenir l'approchant ce que mon peuple
mérite vous venez de vous inviter un
poison qui vous offrira humour le
panthéon apprenez nos rituels et on
aurait peut-être trouverez-vous la
rédemption ou la mort que vous méritez
c'est tout à part me dire de mourir
alors qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur il y avait une aiguille j'ai
juste voulu voir ce que c'était
s'appuyer dessus du coup on m'a injecté
un venin puissant en témoigne la rougeur
sur mon doigt et une dame m'a annoncé
que j'allais mourir je m'en suis
rajouter une petite dose c'est un peu
comme pour les vaccins anti qu'ovide il
y a à peu près 812 le prévu aux os et
allumer des trucs en fait de ce côté
c'est incroyable
ok ça ça correspond symbole que j'avais
ici
ça c'est la vie d'accord ils sont ils
dans l'ordre non après c'est certes
comme ça c'est d'être pierre mission
nouvelle
missions guérir peut-être qu'il faut que
je fasse un peu comme si je parlais un
ordi je veux guérir là j'en suis à voir
traduit ça je me dis je vais passer par
le basique elle m'a dit apprenez nos
rituels etc j'ai un texte je vais le
dire clairement face à ça et on va voir
ce que ça paie il regarde l'aube depuis
la canopée quand la forêt tout bercé par
un chant mordu sous le zénith il fuit
pour s'isoler au soir il voit danser la
création humaine heureux que les casse
tête et tu es un prédateur et la nuit
tout entier arrivent seront célébrées
quand la forêt tout bercé par un champ
ou baiia
à coucou coucou coucou
je les pentes et j'ai eu la bonne 1 b
s'il mais je les tente et là sur cette
feuille j'ai marqué premier deuxième et
troisième l'oeil ouvre la voie vers le
savoir pour moi j'estime que c'était ce
qu'il fallait savoir au que je meure par
transparence j'ai quand même lui qui est
sûre soleil soleil c'est jaune il ne
sert à rien de rage et seniors klaus
c'est parce que j'ai mis le jeune meneur
pas le deuxième il est clairement sur
ciel ou sur pierre les ciels et en bleu
je vais tenter quand même sur ciel
dommage dans l'est mais quelle part est
le dernier
le verre la canopée tout ça je me dis
bleus en face du ciel jaune en face du
soleil
vert en face de la vie
je ne pensais pas que vous seriez
seulement capable de comprendre la
signification des dieux rituel simple
chance peut-être se fait allumer et puis
j'entends du bruit
très long rien d'autre à l'intérieur
sauvage comme vous nous aurez comprendre
la complexité des mots rituel
ce soir mais je ne suis pas un sauvage
je suis pas comme mon ancêtre moi ce que
je veux c'est faire le bien d'ailleurs
on m'appelle fabien il ya plein de
choses
non non ça va je viens de trouver des
tablettes qui représente sorte de
serpent un dragon un humain et d'autres
figures vraiment très sympathique
un être qui me semble assez maléfique et
pitou you très coloré blanc le plan ça
peut ressembler un truc comme guérir
mais je l'avais pas parce que ça ce
serait la pierre
[Musique]
à tanger envie de regarder dedans il y
avait marqué l'oeil vous ouvre la voie
vers savoir et
à la page s'il ya un truc dedans faut
que j'enlève sa
style et ça c'est le bonhomme avec le
demi cercle de cercle non kg trois
symboles à l'intérieur de sa la c3
symbole dont je n'ai pas connaissance
pour le moment c'est manquez pas la
gopro donc trois symboles à l'intérieur
j'ai trois symboles du bonhomme qui va
nulle part donc je n'ai pas trop regardé
ça maintenant d'accord les trois
symboles que j'ai vu à l'intérieur de sa
sont à l'envers en premier geste celui
ci je crois qu'en 2e g lui en troisième
j'ai dit là il ya des espèces de boue de
lundi est rens avec la mort au bout et
le labyrinthe j'en avais une sorte de
labyrinthe à l'arrière est-ce que ça il
faut que je repère une zone là dessus
peut-être
est ce que c'est un bien dont dans l'ip
a retiré
sa entre mais on va le trouver partout
ou si c'est juste pour m'indiquer
en fait j'essaye de j'essayais de
d'euros terré sur ce grande espèce de
plans quand même un peu
cccc forme là où je me dis peut-être
qu'avec lui il faut que je fasse un
tracé avec ce genre de choses huit jeux
je leur père il nous semble pas en avoir
vu deux identiques ça ressemble un peu
un cas très gelé au dessus
celui-là je leur père aussi ça me paraît
être celui
ci l'a par contre lui je leur père pas
clairement suis là c'est juste une ligne
droite aussi gelé c'est lui
oh
donc ça vous avez peut-être compris le
rituel de la glisse avoir
l'esprit pour comprendre la suite des
nouri
a tanger plus haut jamais
après moi je pense celle là
et du coup après ma faim ce serait là
je compte
[Musique]
català
c'est de ne pas pouvoir vous voir mourir
mon air tacatac c'est pas très gentil
pas reconduire à tanger des bruits qui
correspondent à ce que j'ai là ils
regardent l'aube depuis la can opté
quand la forêt bercé par un chant mordu
sous les ennemis qui fut pour s'isoler
non c'est juste parce qu'il y avait ça
là bas ici qui me faisait penser
célèbres ou y danse
ouais c'est frustrant parce que je
croyais vraiment que j'avais que genre
trois trucs 3 step tu vois et là comme
identifie cinq sont je me dis qu'il faut
peut-être que je les intègre un
deux
trois
tambours
concours et bout
c'est à dire maintenant j'ai s'ils sont
comme le social
waouh t'es qui toi
à temps j'avais voûté par
des japonais
quoi qu'il était sur un bout d'aile
j'ai récolté 7 bruit dont certains
j'arrive pas identifié ça correspond aux
sept lignes de mon poème ou de deux
monts refrain donc j'ai tendance à me
dire c'est assez sexy de me dire que
chaque son correspond à une strophe en
point de départ voulait m loiseau le
pigeon parce que ils regardent l'aube
depuis la canopée et après quand la
forêt et tout bercé par un chant h lui à
un règlement
abbas a fait
il pas danser la création humaine
hp le feu ça marche et c'est un aussi ça
mais ça ressemble après en vrai c'est un
peu plus un regard de la canopée
pendant que le perroquet moeurs
mort 10 ou le zénith et puis pour
s'isoler au soir on va danser la
création humaine heureux que les casse
tête et tu es un prédateur ce galet à
la nuit tout entière ils s'en vont
célébrer george de la jungle
quand la forêt est bercée par un champ
[Musique]
vous avez réussi à comprendre notre
employeur il ne vous reste que le rituel
ardents peut-être avez-vous réellement
une chance et vous motiver simplement
par votre survie où êtes vous réellement
repentant je me le demande moi je suis
un peu europe entend aller frérot
attends je garde tout mais en dix ans
semble écouter on va être honnête cette
étape a été fait en collaboration avec
loïc 1 sur la fin sur l'interprétation
des sons j'ai pas l'oreille absolue et
moi j'entendais juste des grognes qui
grognent j'ai entendu un claque j'ai
entendu un jeu claque j'ai entendu un
choc lac
y est amer
aux des allumettes et j'avais dit à
l'heure ici on dirait que ccra max os
ce style urbain me [ __ ] le feu doit y
avoir quelque chose pour que j'allume
est allumé
j'ai rien laissé de côté
[Musique]
en galets match
c'est ça qui s'allument sur tout
j'adorais ça quand j'étais au lycée
[Musique]
ok quel ci n'a pas marché [ __ ] j'ai
trois vidéos
[Musique]
s'est passé un truc là non
oh j'aime autant vous dire que j'aime
autant vous dire
c'est là où à contenir quelconque c'est
là où j'ai versé mon sens il est tombé
là-dedans oh
la vache
c'est incroyable il ya un truc de fou
là-dedans plaça à verser mon sens dedans
là il ya un écran digital qui est buggé
de aux félicitations seigneur vous avez
accompli l'ensemble de nos rituels merci
d'avoir honoré les miens
toutefois cela ne les ramènera jamais à
la vie il y a des choses que tous les
records du monde ne pourront jamais
changé savez vous ce que vous préparer
sa vengeance m'a coûté l'objet qu'ils
allaient monde cet art fact se nomme
magath est donc venue des étoiles qui
nous permettait de créer n'importe
quelle élection de guérison pour cent
grâce à lui mon peuple prospérer jusqu'à
l'arrivée des montres sur nos terres
vous nous avez pillé massacrés alors que
faire sinon transformer le sag arabes
sont une arme capable de nouveaux jets
la source de notre vie deviendra la
source de votre bord
bongo au d'accueillir un peu
hagard hat a priori c'est là c'est lui
là on avait le symbole d'ailleurs
quelque part là on a des symboles pour
l'instant qu'ils ne disent pas grand
chose
là j'ai l'impression que c'est un jeu où
il faudrait que je réussisse à toutes
allumées que j'appuie sur une touche
elle
[Musique]
aw
oui un peu comme un reverso en fait
lui il actionne ces trois-là et suivant
leur état voilà ça va tout et hindous
toutes allumées est ce que c'est le cas
pour tout le monde et ce que la salle
est un tout autour et ça m'allume au
milieu ou voilà là ça veut dire que la
cij appuyé sur lui que ma théorie est
bonne ça va être un tout la croix
donc là ça va me l'a lu mais je pense
que le but soit toutes allumées soit
tout éteindre on va essayer de tout
allumer donc là pour l'instant on en est
là hélas là j'ai tout allumer l'institut
outils à dieu tu
n'es qu'un clic clic et multi diffusion
des idées que tu étais d'étude
auquel et jean-jacques l'aurait verso on
s'est baladé ça c'est ma life ce genre
de ces le cercle avec l'audi boui-boui
donc cercle cible oui est ce qu'il
existe quelque part oui ça ça veut dire
écrire les espèces de fleurs écrire
mission écrire mission est la fleur avec
le zigouigouis écrire missions nouvelles
j'avais écrit en mission nouvelle
maintenant j'ai erreur j'ai fait une
erreur erreur mission lâché même poids
erreur mission point d'exclamation
peut-être et ensuite du coup il me dit
donc c'est encore une mission écrit aux
nouvelles mesures
l'âge est bon ici ici ça m'a fait venir
ici là qu'est ce qu'il me dit maintenant
babouche ça m'a fait apparaître un
symbole guérir guérir poids guérir
guérir de la vie guérir o'gara tu as
[ __ ] williams
j'avais pas vu la correspondance guérir
d'accord ok c'était le lien entre ça et
ça ok guérir guérir vie vie en bas c'est
ça et en os c'est lui
oh je crois que j'ai crevé au trop de
trop d'infos là mon frère comment sais
tu es de garaad c'est en genre on
utilise le yoga rate jamais te dire oui
il faut commencer
ça va utiliser les eaux garde pour me
tue pour me guérir pas pour monsieur
hors de question que je me
couche j'associe c'est de la
magie
mouafo me guérir les gars je lui ai dit
comment c'est là il me dit un bail
bizarre et eux ils sont tous en mode on
va pas bien en ce moment lui nouvelle
pierre rentrée nouvelle pierre bastien
c'est cool c'est lui que j'avais
d'accord mais ou dans celui que je
connaissait pas peut-être
[Musique]
parce que là j'ai une séquence à trouver
ok
gaubert
blanc
vers
le
s'est passé un truc
pour que c'était vert au départ pour que
ce n'est plus la vère
vers blancs s'est passé à calais ont
planché le truc est peut-être un autre
truc ici dans sa cité
est ce que c'est moi qu'on clanche ça ou
est-ce qui s'enclenche par cycle tant
que j'enlève pas ça clignote
là j'ai clairement fait ça
la salanque l'ange cornu
lacement planches
en fait mais des combinaisons la crème
et calcule le boson devrait plus trop
tarder web en se dépêchant
pourquoi toi et moi on se comprend pas
pourquoi maintenant thé vert pourquoi je
vais faire repasser blanc tu veux du
verre est ce que c'est une demande si
c'est une demande je te mets du verre tu
vois
[Musique]
on
c'est toujours vers maintenance et du
blanc du rouge avec du blanc je te mets
du blog je te le fais sauter là
[Musique]
un début de quelque chose je ne
comprends pas mais j'étais un début
quelque chose la couleur c'est la
couleur demandée
blanc
tu venu vers moi je peux prouver le seul
à le mettre là aussi ok le blanche bleue
maintenant ok le verger au canada ok le
bleu le mettre là après le km là
ok je retiens tout est blanc
[Musique]
cela nourrit son utilisation
q vous diront toujours aussi
les deux confirmations bien sûr ça ce
serait un deux trois quatre ans on
vérifie une séquence ça ça commence par
lui 1
2 ça veut tout en haut
3 et bizarrement servir la
4e place du coup comme il ya cinq trucs
à l'écran c'est plutôt un trop de
fonctionnaires 1 c'est quoi la fleur et
le zimbabwe il brûle brûle fleurs un
hoquet fleurs demi cercle suivi de
trucs quittent leur domicile
fleur de lys air coquet
après cirque cercle avec les couilles à
prendre aux biens mais aussi des fleurs
si pour lui
dernière c'est quoi le dernier
bonhomme et demi cercle demi cercle en
bas bonhomme en haut
c'est utilisé sur des matches de poule
merci d'une patiente est impatiente
doxi nous payons tous les gentils des
scientiques patienter
si pour répondre au sentiment
gestion
il faut y aller faut y aller
c'est très désagréable de se faire
quitter volontairement
[Musique]
i'm alive
alive bon on a on a détruit les derniers
exemplaires j'ai bien l'impression de
cette magnifique pierre de goldorak ce
que j'ai vraiment pas du tout retenu son
nom dès qu'ils meurent a sauvé la vie en
même temps aussi parce qu'il voulait me
l'apprendre du coup je trouve que ça se
tient on a découvert surtout que le plus
dur dans mon métier d'explorateurs sera
d'ouvrir les mâles c'est il était
incroyable je vous en ferai un débrief
je pense sur instagram attendre je peux
enlever ça là à vous aurez une petite
trace au milieu du front surtout on a
passé quand même je pense commencer le
tournage à kedgwick 15h15 heure donc ça
fait 4 heures en fait dans le blog
j'avais dit le et qui viennent me dire
tu en a pour quatre heures
c'est vrai j'en ai vraiment eu pour 4
heures il était magnifique il était
incroyable merci beaucoup à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo merci d'accepter les
partenariats régulier pour permettre
aussi ce genre de gros projets merci à
l'extérieur qui a travaillé dessus
pendant pendant presque un an fait pour
que sa voie le jour moi je savais rien
je ne savais pas la tête que ça avait je
savais rien je j'avais juste de temps en
temps panique mise et il faudra appeler
au budget ils ont une bonne idée j'ai
dit oui et c'est trop fou quoi merci
beaucoup bravo et bravo la vie
[Musique]